but we're going to begin with movement
in multiple investigations involving
former president trump and his
associates there is strong strong
pushback from the justice department
about the release of information
regarding the mar-a-lago surge
investigators say the move could
threaten its ongoing case but that isn't
the only investigation with new
developments this morning trump's former
lawyer rudy giuliani says he's the
target of a criminal probe in another
case a grand jury is looking into
efforts to influence and overturn the
2020 election results captain heritage
is following the mar-a-lago case for us
but we'll start with scott mcfarland on
what's going on with giuliani in georgia
scott good morning nate good morning
giuliani's attorney confirms to cbs news
the former new york mayor appears
tomorrow before that grand jury in
atlanta it's one of several
investigations that are accelerating
with some connection to the former
president or his close confidants
giuliani served as then president
trump's personal lawyer in the weeks
after the 2020 election making unfounded
claims of fraud and misconduct by
georgia election officials i don't have
to be a genius to figure out that those
votes are not legitimate vote giuliani
talked about the grand jury at his new
york city radio show monday they have
now told me that i'm the target i'm a
target of their atlanta investigation it
means that the investigation has
gathered enough evidence to alert the
person that they may face an indictment
and that's serious former president
trump has been under scrutiny for his
own efforts to challenge the georgia
election results including his call to
secretary of state brad raffensberger
days before january 6. trump has denied
all wrongdoing look brad i gotta get
i have to find
12 000 votes another trump ally south
carolina republican senator lindsey
graham asked a judge to block a subpoena
from the georgia grand jury amid
questions about his own phone call to
georgia election officials he argued he
was doing his due diligence before
voting to certify the election and
should be shielded from having to
testify but the judge disagreed there
are many things that they don't have to
answer but that's only for things that
deal with their legislative duties their
official duties it does it's not a get
out of jail free card
graham is expected to appeal in this
case but for now is set to appear before
that grand jury next tuesday the 23rd in
a separate case first reported by the
new york times trump organization chief
financial officer allen weisselberg is
expected to reach a plea deal with new
york prosecutors
in a tax fraud case there tony
a lot of investigations to keep track of
scott thank you very much